[Music]
you're looking at Anaheim California for
WonderCon hi I'm Mark Ellis here on the
street with Rotten Tomatoes asking folks
what movie do you need to see this
summer
probably The Flash movie is going to be
Indiana Jones Guardians of the Galaxy 3.
my guilty pleasure Fast and Furious
Mission Impossible seven absolutely
dude's not coming out this summer then
nothing Transformers Beast Wars Peter
Pan were huge Disney fans as well even
though we might not look like it right
now it might be the DND movie coming out
we'll see Dungeons and Dragons movie
what movie are we all excited to see
this summer just shout it out
right
how about the Flash
but Michael Keaton's Batman that's
that's what I'm looking forward to
that's my guy right there the crossover
isn't gonna bring Ben Affleck Batman
Michael Keaton Batman and even Supergirl
Michael Keaton's back Ben Affleck's back
and the flash is in it I hear too yeah
yeah look I just like to be entertained
so I just want to see a good movie so
flash is one of my favorite superheroes
so I'm really excited to see that movie
there might not be a future
the 10th Fast and Furious movie
no I'm good I'm good I'll pass I mean
what Fast and Furious movie are we on
now
I can turn my brain off and just watch
ridiculous stuns happen and just enjoy
it love it cars falling out of planes
yes I'm here for it what do you think
about fast 10
that means family as we say in the Fast
and Furious franchise it's all about
what a franchise a stability we were
looking for family that's the problem
with having such a big family
how do you choose
[Music]
we're here on the street at WonderCon
and you never know what people are going
to ask me to do
all right I think we got it Mission
Impossible 7.
I love me some Tom Cruise oh come on Tom
Cruise is amazing barely anyone else
really does that in the industry and you
know when he breaks something it's all
the more interesting so I saw that video
of him like skydiving off a motorcycle
in a cliff in Norway if it's bad maybe
it's time to just like stop for safety I
mean he is 60 but if he's willing to do
it why stop
everything
Indiana Jones 5.
I'm a big Harrison Ford fan
we happen to have some minis here it is
the return of the greatest Adventure
character of all time gonna be so well
to see how they tie things together how
they wrap it up how even they just
continue the great work that they've
done it's the Nostalgia it's the why did
I do this for a career when I could have
been a globetrotting uh archaeologist I
love the trilogy and I'm just really
looking forward to just sitting in
theaters with another Indie movie
Indiana Jones is the flawed hero that we
all can relate to and that we all
deserve to see he's the one that takes
all the punches for us and we as the
audience give the punches for him all
right so the last question we're gonna
go around the table here give me your
favorite quote from any of the Indiana
Jones movies snakes why did it have to
be snakes hello Marion it's not the
years it's the mileage
trust me
I'm just making this up as I go along
thank you
[Music]
a lot of great answers from a lot of
fantastic folks here at WonderCon now
it's your turn comment right now and let
us know what movie do you need to see
this summer what movie could you do
without and what's your favorite
characters are you hoping to make
another big screen return thanks for
checking out on the street I'm Mark
Ellis like subscribe and we'll see you
real soon and after you see all the
movies this summer make sure you rate
and review at rottentomatoes.com
um thank you sir nobody's filming here
all right let me let me do some video
that was great y'all
it's good stuff old friend